President Obama's administration has
brought about change I don't think that
can be debated there is everything from
the symbolic to the substantive you know
levels of what it would mean to have an
african-american president and I think
at the same time there have been changes
that were unanticipated that came as a
consequence of his presidency and so
when we talk about the initial moment of
his launch into as a national political
figure which was in that 2004 speech
convention speech in Boston he began
that by saying you know there's not a
black America or white America or a
Latino America but there's the United
States of America and you know that was
entirely untrue you know they were
vastly different realities that very
often correspond did to race or at least
were significantly correlated with race
and ethnicity and so what we've seen
over the course of his two terms has
been a means by which our period in
which is been increasingly visible you
know the distinctions that we see as
citizens based upon these elements of
identity who we are and where we're from
and what kind of communities we live in
and you know what our racial ethnic
background is those things have come to
the foreground and I don't think that
you could possibly have anticipated the
extent to which they have done so and so
when we look at you know black lives
matter and how it emerged one it seemed
kind of paradoxical that for you know
half a century african-americans have
been struggling specifically around the
Voting Rights Act to get you know
increased political electoral
representation and at the point at which
we represented at the pinnacle of
American political power it reverberates
and this kind of a boomerang effect and
we won
with a revitalized grassroots movement
of people who don't necessarily trust
political power people who outside the
establishment and people who were
attempting to kind of move the levers of
political power to the advantage of
disempowered communities and one would
have thought I guess in a kind of naive
perspective on Barack Obama's presidency
you would have thought that those things
would not have been necessarily would
not have been necessary certainly some
of his critics thought that he was going
to govern in such a radical way that it
was going to be you know reparations
handed out in the first week for
african-americans and he's been very
moderate and centrist and often
reluctant to directly engage issues of
race I think that's what some of the
frustration had come from the younger
generation of activists and they took
his moderation as being in some
instances inadequate to the task at hand
I think that there's a lot that's
missing from the public conversation
about race when we talk about race we
most often confront it as an emotional
reality or this kind of subject of
social anxiety or something which we go
oh you know we're really all the same
and you know it's a ridiculous idea that
we separate ourselves in this way which
is true but it's also very facile way of
approaching you know that question
because on a more fundamental level
racism mythology but it's also a very
useful myth and that's the only way it's
been able to endure for as long as it
has particularly in the United States
and so what I mean by that is we look at
things now we talk about race we tend to
say that you know there's a level of you
know mistrust or their stereotypes or
misunderstandings and you know we have
these problems we should all just look
at each other as humans but the fact of
the matter is that things like slavery
and segregation and economic
discrimination these things happen
willfully they weren't the result of
kind of haphazard mistaken approaches to
people who happen to be different from
you and so it means that we don't simply
have to dispel mythology it means we
have to actually grapple with people
having concrete interests that may be
different than the interests of other
communities and so it's not simply
implicit bias in policing the hip has
resulted in disproportionate numbers as
we saw in Ferguson it wasn't simply a
matter of implicit bias or stereotypes
or good you know intentioned
well-intentioned individuals who happen
to have arrested or pulled over more
african-americans and whites we saw that
there was an institutional structural
approach to particular communities that
were being fleeced by a police
department and so we can find those kind
of dynamics again and again and again
and so when we talk about race is going
to be much more intractable than simply
ridding ourselves of maybe some mistaken
ideas that have rattled around in our
heads for some time
you